my freshman year in high school I found
wrestling or wrestling found me mom my
true name is Jacob I'm in the Bible
Jacob wrestled against angel angel
beetle and saved his life hmm and
wrestling has saved my life I grinded at
wrestling it was just something that I
knew I could become great at it and I
started barsky my first year there and I
was just when I walked into the
wrestling room I've always been a huge
WWF fan which deputy now I watch cuoco
again Macho Man Randy Savage Tito
Santana a junkyard dog I mean I grew up
watching those guys and I walked into
the wrestling room one wow where's the
ring and the coaches laughing I mean
that's that different type of wrestling
and that's this is this is college or
Olympic style dress and I was like I
still get the slam guys in their head
right it goes well if you can you can do
it and I go I'm not gonna get in trouble
right they go now of course you can not
gonna get in trouble this competition I
was hitched I was hooked I was I was
just something when I thought that I
could become great at and like I said I
started varsity of my first year and I
just got better and better each and
every year and it was just from the hard
work and dedication through wrestling
and um CIF champ
yeah CIF champ took 6 in the state 3rd
and the Masters on my senior year I was
one after 3 years 3 and a half years of
wrestling that's awesome when I
graduated high school I told my mom you
know I'm gonna go live on my own
and I thought life was easy I thought it
was just kind of a walk in the park and
kind of realized its savage out there
man life is hard life is tough you
there's a lot of demands no mercy no
mercy
and everybody will walk all over you if
they can they'll take everything from
you they'll rape everything from you and
I didn't understand that and I got a job
at a light moving service I was a mover
I worked 16 hour days and there were
hard long days how old at 18 years old
and
I couldn't keep up with the time I was
like I had to wake up super in the
morning how to work super late at night
and in high school we drown with crystal
methamphetamine and all of a sudden I
started doing it again out of high
school and I got addicted to it and that
was making me work you know I was
grinding 16-hour days no problem
partying at night wake up the morning
doing it every single day I'm at
probably at the end of that year I was
at a club and one of the wrestling
coaches that I seen when I was growing
up in high school came up to me he's
like Tito the hue man yeah what's up
coach what do you do with yourself now
well I'm just making ends meet you know
I'm gonna pay my bills my apartment and
you know working at a moving service
place you'll see my thought about coming
back and wrestling I was like I would
love to I just don't really have no
financials to take care of the college
not know for the books he's all I could
possibly get your financial aid man
because even looking good looking good
flying not recognize it at all I went
home that night and I looked in the
mirror and I was saying hi to him now 63
you know 185 pounds I'm a 230 right now
whoa
and I was sucked up pimples all over my
face and I looked in a mirror I didn't
recognize myself and it scared me
because I was turned into my parents mmm
I had a really hard shaking reality that
I had to check myself and it was just a
question I still do to this day always
question myself I look in the mirror and
I say what are you doing yourself right
now do you want to turn to your parents
and I was like no I mean thank God my
mother's sober now my father I'm not
sure if he is but it was hard it was a
challenging point in my life that I had
to make a decision and at that point I
made the decision I called my work I got
home that night slept all day Monday
when I wake up call my work and I said
I'm not gonna come in today they're like
well we need you here I'm gonna go check
out this College thing no we need you
here we needed for this shift I was like
I can't come in like well you're fired I
go you know what I guess I quit walking
to the wrestling room I walked into the
coach's office at Goldman's junior
college and I said I'm here I want to
try I want to see what this college can
really give back to me I want to wrestle
again I want to get to I want to get a
college degree
and he smiled and he says you know I
think we could help you
family financial aid I got a stipend
because I'm Mexican American I got went
through college I won the state title
that year and good Golden West junior
college and then I started training with
the guy into by the name of tank Abbott
thank you yeah back in he's in the
beginning stage yeah he's oc6 so his
wrestling coach is Paul Herrera who was
my high school wrestling coach and he
was like hey come train come train with
tank I like heating like it punched me
right boxer all the wrestlers had never
understood the Bison crazy and is a
monster but in the wrestle with him and
I would take him down that will I mean
it was well it was it was easy and
people the coach was like look like
button
who is this kid and like I said I was a
state champion at the time for gold most
junior college 195 pounds and I just
thought that you know maybe I could do
this fighting thing I watch the UFC 13 I
think it was Jerry Bohlander who won the
tournament he submitted Kevin Jackson
who was a gold medalist in wrestling for
the United States and he submit him in
the finals and all they kind of changed
bolander it's been named what's really
familiar and I looked back my high
school wrestling god dates and I
wrestled him and I beat him I think it
was like attended to where I was like
wow I want to get chance to this I told
tank it would take me and gave me a
fight of this I want to try this man he
was uh-huh you want to fight him this no
I want to all travel to China I'm not
training with you I mean I got boxing
guys I'm working with I got my hands
pretty heavy I mean I want to learn I
want to do this because alright we'll
see we can do and then May 30th 1997 I
got my first try as an alternate I was
in college I was a scholarship student
at the time so I couldn't compete as a
professional and so I fought for free
well first and only UFC fighter to ever
fight for free and really that's how
much I mean I love to compete I want to
see how good I truly was and I fountain
was it Augusta Georgia
Yosi 13 May 30th 1997 and I stopped the
guy
Wes Albritton in 22 seconds and I was
also I think that day a star was born
there
[Music]